should you self publish your book so
while ago I made a video about the
publishing industry and me writing my
book and I got a comment from our
YouTube viewers love you guys able aid
studios a lower loyal viewer who wrote
in to say definitely a great question
love the answers what do you think about
these self publishing companies coming
out could they be an option go alright
so here we go I have four criteria that
I thought I would look at and I base it
all of what is your intention your
motivation your reason for wanting to
have a book and depending on what that
reason is that I helped make a decision
if you want to go with the publisher or
if you want to self publish the first is
credibility a lot of people think that
having a book gives you more credibility
so when you're going in and talking to
customers you can show them your book if
you are trying to get a speaking gig or
consulting gig or in the media you can
show them your book and be a recognized
author and if that's important to you
then you need to get the book out there
and if the publisher is not willing to
take it on then you can sell publish
right I think a recognized publisher
gives you a little bit more credibility
than doing it yourself but if you can't
get that publisher then gosub publish
because you want that credibility now
saying that I think that argument that a
book helps give you credibility is
getting it's going down right it's not
as important as it used to be I don't
have a book and I can open any door that
I want to open right I have a popular
website I have a popular YouTube channel
I have a popular Twitter account so many
other ways now to reach people besides
books that can add to your credibility
I've been in the media been in Forbes
I've been in the Wall Street Journal
been in the new york times I've been in
all these big publications without ever
having a book you don't need to have a
book to give you the credibility so I
think it can help it can add to it but
it's not as important as it used to be
number two is just to have a book you
want a book right it's on your bucket
list I want to write this book before I
die and if that's your goal that's your
reason for having a book then go right
the book right and again if you can't
get a publisher then gosub publishing
route it doesn't matter so much which
one you go to because you just want to
get a book out there because your reason
for writing the book isn't the
credibility using expert status it's
because you want to have a book out
there that you can share your grandkids
and say here's what i wrote so if that's
your incentive then just go out and sell
publish you don't need a huge publisher
or all that headache or hassle to get it
out there number three is money you're
doing it for the money you want to make
money from the books and the interesting
thing here is if you go with the
publisher you're not going to make any
money right the money that you get paid
is is tiny and they're out you know
selling it and so you make your money
from a book doing well and then you
getting more recognition more awareness
doing more media and that leads to more
more opportunities right the more your
name is known the more you can get big
deals big clients if you're trying to
make money from the book you want that
to be a moneymaker for you then you're
much better to go self-publishing
because there's a small cost to actually
make the book and you get to keep the
entire spread you keep the whole margin
off of that so if your if your money
making idea is to make it from the book
you saw published if you're trying to
make money from broader awareness then
go and try to get the publisher on board
and number four is impact and this is
the most important one for me okay I
don't need the book as a credibility
tool I don't want to write a book just
to write a book and and I'm not trying
to write a book to make money from it I
don't even care about a book I don't
need to have a book it's never been a
priority for me that's why I've never
done it right in my 12 plus years of
running this business I've never had a
book because it's never been important
to me what what I care about is impact I
my goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs right I believe in
entrepreneurs I want on terms to believe
in themselves and whatever medium helps
communicate that message and reaches
people that's where I'm going to be and
so I started with my website and I had a
ton of people hit the website we've had
20 million plus people on the website
I'm doing a lot of these YouTube videos
why because he had impact because we
have three and a half million views on a
channel because you guys are leaving
common
saying Ebony's videos are awesome
they're really helping me with my
business or their inspiring me they keep
me going that stuff fuels me right I
love seeing that stuff come in so
wherever there's an impact and
opportunity that to impact entrepreneurs
that's where I want to be so for me the
book is at just another way to impact
entrepreneurs and in my head making a
self-published book doesn't have the
impact to me to go through all of that
work to write the book and then just
mark it all myself and not have any
backing I'd rather put that time into
making youtube videos I can do that I
can get my message out there much more
clearly with with a greater reach by
hitting you guys up on YouTube then I
could with a sub published book so for
me I'm only doing a book if I get a big
publisher on board with a sizable
advance you know I want a publisher
who's behind me who's not just going to
put it out there put on the bookshelves
and that's it right so I want them
committed with a sizable advance I want
this to be important to them because I
want to have a bigger impact on the
world if I can't get a big couple of
strong board with a sizable advance I
won't do it I'll keep making videos I'll
keep answering your questions right
wherever the impact is going to be
that's where I want to be so some
publishing can work it can be awesome it
just depends on what your motivation is
so again I'd look at number one you need
to credibility number to do you just
want to have a book number three are you
doing it for the money or number four
are you doing it for the impact
hopefully that answers your question if
you guys have others leave in the
comments below and I'll make a video
reply thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe and if you
liked this video you want to see more
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much for watching I'll see you soon
if you want some believe in your inbox
every week to keep you motivated check
out the link below to join my newsletter